[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by my colleague Mrs
Christina Ellis and we are here to take
your calls about pretty much anything
you want to talk about as long as we
have an answer if we don't we'll tell
you straight to your face but uh we got
a pretty good track record here and we
can talk about getting out of debt
investing Building Wealth going to
college debt free how to get out of
those crummy student loans that are
hanging around your neck and the number
to call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you've been a long
time listener first-time listener and
you're like well I'm not one of those
people who calls in I'm going to
encourage you I think today is your day
if you've been sitting on the sideline
lines and I know you have questions
because I get about 78 Instagram
messages a day with like four paragraphs
I'm like you gotta call into the show I
can't sufficiently answer this because
then we're gonna go back and forth with
my little thumbs easier to do it talking
to you so triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
earning is kicking us off in Wichita
Ernie welcome to the show
hey thank you and uh I'm only two weeks
into this so I'm taking that chance
today I love it well we appreciate that
how can we help
well uh just some coaching
um
I'm looking for uh some coaching on
weather to just jump in and pay off our
house
um we my wife and I are retired
educators
and uh
we have the means through uh an early
retirement incentive from our district
I think to pay off our house that's uh
within five years that's on a three
percent uh a vehicle that's on a three
percent and a vehicle that's on a zero
percent so in one year's time I believe
that we can pay all three of those off
and be debt free
I love it so uh first of all
congratulations and thank you for your
service to your community we need
awesome Educators out there and sounds
like you guys had a good run how long
were you educated for
my wife for 37 years
um she's been retired four years now
and 35 for me I'm two months out of it
wow that's incredible okay so let's talk
about this early retirement how much are
you getting
well it's a pretty sweet deal and you
don't recognize it when you uh sign up
for things in your 20s but I'm uh she's
receiving her version of that and we've
been just for the last four years
um uh just throwing that straight into
Investments with our advisor she's
pulling like 65 000 a year to stay at
home it's it's called The Bridge again
it's it was intended the bridges from
age 60 to age 65 when you can pull start
pulling Social Security if you're
interested so we're basically earning
our paycheck for not coming to work and
that goes for how long
for five years so we're three we're four
years into her five uh my uh five years
starts in April okay I had to retire
prior to age 60 so I wouldn't lose out
on part of that benefit so and starting
in April uh my share of that is going to
be uh six figures probably 115 120 000.
awesome uh five years a year for five
years and my thought was we have around
87 000 left on our home
and we have
two vehicle loans that are uh real Honda
that's we're three years and two so we
got two years left on it what's the loan
on that
that's I'm sorry I don't have the
monthly in front of me no just a total
loan what do you owe on the car the uh
probably 20. okay in the other car
uh 28. okay is that all of your debt
yep okay pretty good and do you have any
other well there's no discover bills you
know
uh do you have any other money in
savings
a quick hand on hand stuff probably uh
fifteen thousand
and then beyond the five years what
happens then what are you guys going to
do for retirement do you have any other
retirement savings
we're receiving our our Kansas Public
Employees Retirement
um so we have that for a lifetime
um
and we're pulling in the between the two
of us uh probably six grand a month from
that uh and we're currently well over
currently and that's on top of the
five-year deal when you get your full
income for five years sweet deal man
yeah well if you guys can put this to
good use we can get rid of all this debt
but right now you don't have a pile of
cash to throw are you getting these
checks monthly
uh mine will start monthly she has been
receiving hers monthly and it's been
rolling straight into Raw
okay
well we've been living on prior to to
prior to my retirement in August it was
my paycheck and her uh retirement from
the state we're currently living off of
my retirement and her retirement and
we're not touching anything we're you
know adjusting to coming home with less
money making do making and making some
adjustments and trying to save as much
as possible but our retirement uh our
own personal savings through our 401ks
and roths over the last 35 years we have
over a million dollars worth of money
and Investments there we go that's it
don't bury the lead on me Ernie
sorry so you guys can you can withdraw
from that tax-free at this point
yes okay plus you have this fantastic
income
yes so I see that something pretty sweet
you've got two options here one is you
withdraw from the retirement accounts if
you don't have all the money and we pay
off the cars today
the cars would come first and then the
other side of this is you could use your
future income which you have plenty of
for the next five years to clean up all
of this debt and after the five years
you're completely debt free and you
never touch the retirement account and
it continued to grow
foreign
would it be smart to because we're uh we
are doing fine with just our two Public
Employee Retirement ours our sixth Grand
is a month uh
when I start pulling that in April to
just
let's get rid of all of that in one year
because that monthly paycheck from that
that uh Bridge payment
in one year's time I will have received
enough money to have paid off
certainly the house and the two cars
yeah certainly the house in one car and
maybe two cars I mean instead of waiting
I want all of this just and so
regardless of how you mix it up and and
also I'd cut up those Discover Cards I
want you to discover Freedom instead and
you guys are gonna have a much better
retirement without playing with debt you
don't need to you guys have built such
an incredible level of wealth there's no
reason to try to do the zero percent or
the three percent you're throwing out
all the interest rates
Ernie you don't need this anymore you
don't need the lenders you've become the
bank my friend that's why you do this
stuff yeah you said you're new to this
you're doing so great but just have that
little bit of a mind shift set shift
where you go we aren't a family that
does debt no more debt we've got the
money to move forward with such freedom
in retirement that changes the game in
retirement man now what could you do
when you don't have a payment in the
world not a mortgage payment not a car
payment you're not worried about the
interest rate you're worried about Ernie
and his family and his legacy
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Music]
when the team gets together Ramsey
Solutions we talk a lot about our
mission to change America's toxic money
culture because it makes us mad to see
people get trapped by debt or to watch
kids sign away their future with student
loans and for the folks who work here
this isn't a jlb this is a mission to
change lives and if you share that
passion you've got to check out all the
exciting roles Ramsey Solutions is
looking to fill ASAP there's never been
a better time to find a job doing work
you love we especially need developers
and ux designers and writers to help us
build digital products that actually
change people's lives and you can see
what it's like to do work that matters
before you ever apply go follow us on
Instagram and Facebook by searching
Ramsay careers and go apply for your
dream job sorry your dream job at
ramseysolutions.com careers that's
ramseysolutions.com
slash careers and before you ask we
don't have any remote positions we are
all Under One Roof multiple buildings
but multiple roofs here and uh just
south of Nashville Tennessee so if
you're looking to make the move it is
worth it it's a wonderful City and a
great place to work ramseysolutions.com
careers
open phones this hour at triple eight
eight two five five two two five b joins
us up next in San Diego B welcome to the
show
hey guys thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can Christina and I help
um okay so I'm kind of nervous it's all
right you're gonna do fine we're
freaking out too if it helps thank you
uh well it's kind of bad but uh so I
called
back in I want to say like April 2020 uh
for my debt-free screen and it was um
with uh Steve Ramsey and Dr John deloney
and I was like super excited
um especially like heading into a
pandemic I just felt like super relieved
that I had gotten out of debt
um but then like
I saved up the emergency fund I started
investing like doing everything that
um like following the baby steps
and then I
um kind of like drained my emergency
account to start a Roth IRA
um with like a financial Pro
and um I never really got like my
emergency fund built back up before like
Murphy started hitting so that's how it
goes I know it's like I kind of ended up
back in in debt and I was like
well I'll I'll make a goal to pay it off
in a year and
um and that year passed a couple months
ago
and I'm still like looking at this 10
grand that I owe and uh what kind of
debt is it I'm
it's on my car
okay so you didn't have the emergency
fund you had car problems you had to get
a new car and so you bought a car on a
loan
yes okay
um I I bought it for 14 and over the
past year I've only really paid off like
about four of it you just been making
the minimum payments pretty much
yeah I essentially just like rounded up
to like the like to 500 so it's like
I've been making extra payments on it I
just haven't been like intentional with
it
but how much um and I just feel like a
hypocrite and I'm like that's all right
hey you know what Dave's not here we're
gonna treat this like a Planet Fitness
this is a judgment-free Zone today we're
not gonna beat you up
the fact that you called you showed up
you were vulnerable and honest it's okay
yeah how much debt did you pay off the
first time
wow how long did that take
um
it took me about a year and a half
to do that and that was the same person
who stands before us today saying they
can't pay off ten thousand in a year
yeah why is that
I honestly I really need to like
I've been actually thinking about that
for a couple days now but
I when I was paying all that stuff off I
lived
um on like the east coast and I didn't
really like have much to like do where I
lived and now I live in San Diego and
I'm doing all these like crazy fun
things what I'm hearing is your
lifestyle creeped up you got a little
bit lazy and we went we're in California
let's have a good time and here we are
exactly
I'm just like I don't need to pay off my
car but like in the back of my mind I'm
like why do I have this stupid debt like
I hate this
um when you called in back in 2020 and
you were talking through your debt-free
scream what was your why in that moment
when they were asking you what motivated
you to pay off forty seven thousand
dollars in debt what was your motivation
then
okay
um honestly I had two motivations I
wanted um I kind of like wanted to prove
to my family that like you didn't need
to rely on that
um because like my whole family
background is like you know we lost our
house during the 2008 recession and all
that stuff so I've just kind of always
had like Financial trauma surrounding my
family
um so like that was my biggest push was
to like
be an idol for like my younger siblings
if that makes any sense oh no that makes
sense it absolutely does you that was
your never again you said my family tree
is going to look a lot different because
the decisions that I made I think we
need to channel back to those days and
go I know it I hate to be here and I
made decisions that weren't great and I
used my emergency fund as an investment
tool and I know I did I made some
mistakes great let's pick it up and move
forward and go what can we do now so
what is your income
okay
um
it just increased that I make about 8
000 a month
B that's an amazing income why is this
debt not gone you know two three months
from now
that's a great question can you live off
nothing for the next two months and
clear the debt R2 so in my brain I'm
like
I don't even like my car it was just
something I bought real quick in like
how much could you sell the car for
okay
I don't know probably 12 or 14 000. and
how much do you have in the bank
I want to say around seven thousand okay
this is a non-issue b if you want to be
debt free today go sell the car and get
you a five six seven eight thousand
dollar car
yeah that you like more and be who are
you hanging out with in San Diego it
sounds like you've changed communities
you've got a different lifestyle do you
have any other friends who are Frugal
who are kind of thinking the same way
you are about money
or at least the way you want to think
about money
card point
s
but
um
but are you married every time
oh no okay no no
no no no no no no no she said okay I'm
just figuring out who we can use to keep
you accountable on this journey because
it sounds like it's pretty lonely and
you're just out there living la vida
loca with no one to tell you hey maybe
we should pay off some debt and make
some grown-up decisions
yeah exactly yeah and this was also like
my first time sort of like living alone
too so like back when I paid off debt I
you know I had like roommates that were
like a part of the process and they were
just like checking things off with me
and stuff so now it's just me and my dog
that was fun
it's like you do great in community I
would encourage you to find a local FPU
class and actually go to that and get
cheerleaders around you get other people
around you who are walking through this
journey who are motivated who aren't
going to be people that you're comparing
yourself to and feeling that fomo like
you want people around you who will be
your cheerleaders and are excited for
you paying off debt not talking about
the latest the latest credit card reward
deal yeah have you been through fbu
that's a bad idea we have
um
twice I think I've been through it I
used to make it like a yearly goal to go
to do it again but then
um since like the pandemic and all that
stuff and all the stuff shut down I just
kind of like lost track of
um well you know what they say be here
third time's the charm and so what we're
gonna do is gift you uh Financial Peace
University for one year it's got the
latest videos in there including a new
new lessons with Dr John deloney and
myself and I hope that's the motivation
you need I can't sit here and and make
you motivated you've got to find your
own why and use that to drive your
budget your behavior your lifestyle and
you have an amazing income and you have
money in the bank throw six of that at
the dead take it down to four and this
month we're debt free on your next
paycheck it's that simple it's just you
have to decide am I gonna do this stuff
or am I going to keep living in the
shame and guilt and baggage or do I just
want to move forward completely debt
free once and for all you get to decide
I hope you make the right choice this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel host of the fine print
entree leadership podcast as well as
co-host of smart money happy hour joined
by Christina Ellis best-selling author
you can check out all the shows I just
mentioned as well as this one on the
Ramsey Network or wherever you listen to
podcasts open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ryan joins us up next in Kansas Ryan
welcome to the show
yeah thanks for having me I appreciate
it absolutely what's going on
well my wife and I we're both 45 years
old and we will be completely out of
debt about three years mortgage and
house and everything awesome that's
great we're excited about that uh my
wife will be taking over her parents uh
catering business probably in the next
three or four years and just kind of
having a hard time figuring out kind of
the fine you to see how we're going to
do that that type of thing so just kind
of wanted to get your guys's input
um they've kind of basically have said
that they want her to kind of run it and
then kind of split the profit 50 50.
um
and I don't think they've really planned
much for retirement I'm not sure if
that's
necessarily the best way to do it you
know we want them to have a good
retirement we want them to enjoy
retirement but it kind of feels like
it's going to be you know pretty big
burden on my wife and a strain on the
business
we would rather not you know
um
have to take out a loan to buy the
business
you know and that type of thing so
they're saying hey instead of you buying
the business from us and giving us money
we can do this where we get a certain
percentage of the profit over a certain
period of time
well the the period of time is kind of
the I mean they're kind of they want it
forever that's the retirement plan
that's pretty much yeah I'm not taking
that deal
yeah what happens if they live 35 more
years
that's what yeah that's what I asked too
we need to see could be on paper it
could be retirement and
and we could when we retire at 65.
and still have to work to fund their
retirement yeah you said seems like
several times have you all actually sat
down with them and had a very clear
conversation about the numbers where
you've actually seen the numbers and had
clear expectations laid out
now we've tried we did this about a year
ago they're very secretive about how
much they make how much that this
business that's always good taking over
the business from people who won't tell
you anything
yeah and so it's just if we love them
but it's just kind of frustrating
because we never know I mean they're
both 75
uh we want them to enjoy retirement we
don't expect to get the business for
free or anything like that we you know
willing to work with them but that's why
I think settling on a number it's like
what what does the business bring in
what's the top line revenue you have no
idea
no idea I know my wife if this wasn't
her parents business and someone said
hey you want to take over this business
I won't tell you how much it makes I
won't tell you anything about what our
net profit is but do you want to give us
50 of the profits forever you would tell
them to kick rocks and pound sand
wouldn't you exactly yeah and so we're
not going to move forward with this
until they're going to be honest and
we're going to see these numbers on
paper not just hearsay well and even
then you may not want to move forward
with it but your wife wants to take over
the catering business
well yeah I mean she's worked for him
for you know 20 years you know it's hard
work that's different than does she want
to just because it's comfortable and
it's what she knows
but she kind of wants to know
how much she's going to be making you
know and that kind of thing too is she
working there full time right now yeah
yeah well what does she make right now
as a full-time employee she makes 50
000. so ideally she's making a lot more
than that if she is an owner of the
business now that's before the split
profits
yeah and that's only a thing we don't
know we don't know if it's going to be
they may be pulling in 60
000
and now we got to split that and it's
30.
yeah okay well I would I would tread
lightly carefully with legal
documentation not because we don't trust
them but because we don't want
relationships to get severed in this
process
right okay so I also I would parse this
out you taking over this business is not
their retirement plan
their lack of planning does not
constitute your emergency in the
scenario
okay and so if the plan is hey unless
this goes perfectly and this business
runs perfectly we can't put food on the
table that's a dangerous situation
and so I would make sure that we have
very clear rules on what this is going
to look like because what happens if
there's a down year
right yeah I mean uh there's so much
fluctuation with uh with catering in
general and you know if you're like
covid was really hard yeah and the thing
with her mom there's a lot of the baking
and decorating and so when she retires
she's gonna have to hire somebody to
kind of fill that role I don't know I
think it's just going to be kind of a
strain on the business to support
yeah you may have to hire outside people
which will be another expense which will
reduce profits it sounds like it's very
messy and sticky especially with the
emotional aspect I'm sure that the fact
that the parents don't have a lot of
retirement and savings is nerve-wracking
so then your wife may feel a little bit
of an obligation to continue forward
with this business to help her parents
but I would also challenge you to
consider the option of selling the
business to someone else like
potentially if your wife doesn't want to
keep this specific business maybe she
wants to start her own catering company
from the ground up the parents can still
sell the business to someone else and
then they have that clear boundary that
hard break where they no longer have
their foot in the business they no
longer have control of the finances and
then they could possibly have a little
Nest Egg to move forward with in their
retirement and again you want that in
writing unfortunately we would buy it
from them and they're like well we're
afraid we're going to run out of money
for retirement
so I know it sounds harsh but that's not
your problem
and so you say hey I'm willing to
purchase it outright but we're not going
to do this deal where you just get 50
forever we're not comfortable with that
unless you say you get 50 up until X
number and we call that good
and if you never hit that number that's
a risk they're taking as well
a number of years to do that
all this to say this is messy and it's
given me anxiety and so I would tread
with a lot of caution here and get
everything on paper and even in the
contract you might want to say hey we
have the right to sell this business and
give you half of whatever the sale is
and call that good and if they go well
that's not enough for us well sorry
that's what we agreed to because who
knows I don't want your wife stuck with
this because now she's trying to cover
her parents retirement plan
yeah I would also encourage you when you
sit down to have this conversation you
may need to have a third party in the
room like an attorney who can kind of
bring some reality to that conversation
because with it being her parents it
might be easy for them to say hey like
don't cross this boundary like I'm the
parents you're the daughter and they can
bring in a lot of emotion and drama and
manipulation and go we raised you you
owe us this and you need someone who can
be completely objective and just bring
the facts and say this is what is normal
in a business transition this is what is
expected and it's not personal it's not
feelings but this is this is healthy
parties they'll have ways they can
structure it to where it protects both
both of you
okay so and what are you working
full-time outside of this business yeah
I teach yeah so I I work full time and
and you know we're you know I've got a
we've got a 401k and an IRA
um
we're on a good pay you know good plan I
think we just kind of need to get this
ironed out yeah well and you guys being
completely dead free house and
everything three years from now is going
to help out this whole situation because
you've got wiggle room and margin in
case the business takes a few years to
get off the ground if she does take it
over
okay
all right well I appreciate so much you
guys is uh wisdom man yeah absolutely
appreciate the call man and I'm gonna
send you a copy of Dave's book entree
leadership and this is his playbook for
how he started this business on a card
table in his living room and is now has
grown it to this amazing Empire and I
think it's going to help you guys get
some parameters and boundaries and help
you understand the right way to run a
business because I don't know how this
business has been running we don't know
anything about this business but this
will lay out exactly how to do hiring
and firing and structure pay and a lot
of the leadership principles as well
because she hasn't been in that
leadership role she's been an employee
and so it's a very different side of the
coin there
yeah and family businesses can be tricky
but you know thankfully you've seen
several successful family businesses
through hosting the entree leadership
podcast it can work but only with a lot
of intentionality and a lot of honesty
exactly so hang on the line Jenna's
gonna pick up we're going to send you a
copy of Entre leadership and I hope that
helps you guys make a wise decision
about this family business and if it's
not right it's okay to say no thank you
and the business goes away it gets sold
it's not your problem thanks for calling
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis this
hour this is the Ramsay show open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Lilly is in Austin Texas Lily
how's it going
Hi how are you guys doing great how are
you how can we help I'm doing good my
question is more in college related
um I love that my question is how can I
present your philosophy to an
overwhelmed 17 year old
like it's about to go to college next
year
when you say overwhelmed explain that to
me what does overwhelmed look like for
um our parents really didn't
um set up any accounts
um they are not familiar with getting
him ready to go to college
so just the prospect of filling out
scholarships things like that are
are not in front of him to do so I
recently found you guys this year
um and I definitely want him to go this
route it's ultimately his decision
um but I just don't know how to present
the philosophy to him let me know that
he can be receptive to it yeah Lily are
you his sister
yes oh way to be an amazing sister how
old are you
27.
well thank you thank you for doing that
we need more sisters and siblings and
mentors who are willing to just step up
and get in the Gap and say hey you don't
have to go into debt for college and I'm
going to walk you through this so I'm
really thankful you're taking ownership
of that thank you so whenever you talk
to him about college right now does he
get defensive is he receptive what's
kind of his perspective and take on it
um right now he's interested in going to
Community College we live in different
states
um and he wants to go to Medicine
um at his field of choice so I
definitely don't want him to like go
into that traditional route of just
going
starting his biology degree and then
just getting student loans left and
right to cover everything when there are
so many other options yeah but he has to
put forth some work in order to get
those options yeah well the very first
place I would start is with our borrowed
future documentary and the reason I love
this is because it paints different
stories of one why you shouldn't go into
debt so we've got stories about people
who went into tremendous debt we have
somebody who is a doctor who went into a
million dollars in student loans debt
loan debt and he's literally crying in
the documentary because it's you know
completely affected his life in a very
dramatic way but we also have success
stories of people who went to school
without debt through scholarships
through working their way through
through maybe going to a different
College than they originally envisioned
so you kind of have that picture painted
for a student where you don't
necessarily have to just give them a
bunch of tactics straight away but they
can see the why themselves they can see
the why through real life stories so I
would start there because we've had a
lot of students watch that and go wow
like light bulb moment I I didn't
realize that I could do this debt free
and then after that I would start
getting into some of the tactics once
he's got that motivation you know start
walking through you know exactly how you
do that I love that Community College is
the first place that he's looking
because a lot of states have free
community college do you know
um has he looked into the different
community colleges he wants to go to I
know Texas has some amazing programs
um so he currently recites in Florida I
live in Texas
um I I've mentioned to him the
alternative of coming to Texas because
um UT Austin is awesome for example
um so he's looking he's but he just he's
centered into just going to one
Community College in the same district
he's graduating from and that's a great
option but there are so many
um that he could look into yeah well I I
do love that that's the first step that
he's looking at we've got some great
resources to help them we've got a book
called debt-free degree
um by Anthony O'Neill I've written a
couple books Confessions of a
scholarship winner and how to graduate
debt free to help walk through the every
single step process of what he needs to
know so I personally won over a half a
million dollars in scholarships got
super motivated to apply that direction
but I also encourage students even if
they don't get scholarships even if they
don't get a full ride there are so many
different ways to go to school debt-free
especially now there are incredible
tuition assistance programs so a lot of
companies now will pay for your college
education while you're earning money and
it sounds like he's pretty independent
at this point like he's not going to
have a lot of help After High School
paying for his bills so having a
employer like a Starbucks or Amazon or
one of the many companies that offer
this give him a paycheck every week and
also pay for his college education could
really help him set to help set him up
for success in his finances
okay I would just encourage you to walk
with him through this because it is
overwhelming you said he's kind of
overwhelmed and maybe you could even set
up like a a weekly call with him so that
he doesn't feel like he's on his own you
know pick up one of these books and go
through week by week and say okay today
we're going to talk about Community
College I want you to come to our call
with you know a list of five community
colleges in the area I want you to
research their programs I want you to
research you know how you can transfer
to a four-year school after that and
then maybe the next week you talk about
tuition assistance programs maybe he
wants to start at a four-year school and
you can find an amazing tuition
assistance program where he can kind of
work through that maybe the next week is
a little module on scholarships and you
can help him research come to this
meeting with 10 scholarships you want to
apply for this week I think that it's
amazing that you're helping him walk
through this process because Simply
Having a partner with him in this can
help reduce so much of that anxiety you
know I'm so thankful for my mom because
you know she didn't have the money to
pay for my college education but what
she couldn't give me in money she gave
me with in help she was willing to sit
in the library with me as I filled out
scholarship applications she was willing
to do the research with me and tell me
it's going to be okay I know you feel
overwhelmed right now but I am in the
ring with you you are not alone in this
it's so good coach in the corner like
that and Lily you're you're one of those
people I mean you're would you consider
yourself like another parent to him
um I'm the sister
um but it's just like with having this
big of a god
there's an extra level of responsibility
because there is so much life experience
in between us well it sounds like you
you care more about his future and him
going to college debt free than your
parents do
they're normal
um so I'm starting to get them to come
to the weird wagon the weird wagon
that's my new favorite term for the
Ramsay way well Lily we are cheering you
on and uh we're gonna gift you a link to
go watch borrowed future and uh maybe
you guys could I know your your State's
apart but maybe you could hit play at
the same time and then get on the phone
and have a conversation about it after
and maybe incentivize them you know
maybe say hey I'm gonna buy you dinner
I'm gonna venmo you some money to get
some dinner as an incentive to watch
this with me on a Friday night virtually
and then we're going to talk about it
after and that will start some really
cool conversations that otherwise
wouldn't have happened
and then it's not you talking at him
it's him coming to you saying hey I
heard this in that dog is that true
about how the student loan oh my
goodness yeah I want to take debt off
the table completely and so if you can
help me get creative and find ways to do
that I'm all for it and uh what's really
cool is we're celebrating the one year
anniversary of borrowed future and we're
doing a big celebration launching the
film on YouTube October 17th at 7 pm
Central with a watch party
and if you don't know what bar future is
we keep talking about it it's our
award-winning documentary that uncovers
the dark side of the student loan
industry and we believe every high
schooler every parent of a high schooler
everyone in education needs to watch
this film and share it with someone that
you know needs to see it as well so you
can uh following the watch party on
Monday you can view borrowed future on
YouTube for free for the first time on
demand and of course the film will still
be available on Amazon Prime video Apple
TV Google Play ramseysolutions.com where
you can rent it ad free and so let's
continue to disrupt this toxic student
loan industry and show kids that there
is another path it doesn't have to end
with frustration and anxiety going no
one told me that I was going to end up
300 000 in debt and I don't have the
dream job and now I need to get a
different job just to pay the bills and
it feels like I'll never get out of this
thing
and what's so interesting is one of the
most common things I hear from people
when I tell them what I do that I help
people pay for college is I just wish
someone would have sat me down in high
school and explained to me that I didn't
have to go into student loan debt and
it's crazy that there are so many 17
year olds that they don't have anybody
having that conversation with them no
one's sitting down and telling them
there is another way you don't have to
[ __ ] your financial future when
you're 17 and 18 years old and I just
encourage you to share this documentary
and help students realize that they
don't have to go into debt plant that
seed I know sometimes 17 year olds can
be resistant to that message they can
say like they're overwhelmed like she
said her brother is overwhelmed we were
all teenagers we remember right but just
planning that seed you don't know how
deep that seed will go just plant this
seed and give them the opportunity to
have that Awakening amen so join us
Monday night for our borrowed future
watch party October 17th 7 PM Central on
our YouTube channels you can go right
now and RSV AP click notify me on the
Ramsay shows YouTube channel we'll get a
reminder going how cool would be if
thousands of us all across the country
are watching this together sparking
conversations with the Next Generation
helping them go to college completely
debt free love it that puts us out in
the books my thanks to my co-host
Christina Ellis all the folks in the
booth and you America will be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by best-selling author Christina
Ellis and we are taking your calls at
AAA
825-5225 you need a little confirmation
motivation affirmation sometimes you
just need that little nudge Christina to
go okay I thought I was gonna do the
thing and now I'm gonna do the thing I
just needed a little boost of confidence
because there's a lot of voices and
noise in today's culture and we're like
the you know unbiased but biased third
party who's going to tell you what to do
and hopefully it ends up working out for
you so triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number LD joins us
up first in Atlanta Georgia LD welcome
to the show
hi good afternoon how are you doing
good good
um thank you for taking my call sure
um so uh I'm starting a new job
um next month
and
um uh on the on the encouragement with
my for my friend Brian he recommended um
to call you guys because I'm I'm trying
to understand
where um
uh or which which retirement benefit I
should I should pick okay but that's
that's best for me okay
sweet and what's the job
um it's a engineer a researcher very
cool are you getting a raise from what
you're doing previously
yeah I did um like 10 or so very nice
okay so what are your retirement options
so the first option is
um a 401a defined benefit uh it is two
percent times years of service
based on the 24 highest consecutive
months
it comes with a 10-year vesting
requirement
and employment contribution is six
percent
uh on that
um is that a match or is that just
they're going to put in six percent even
if you do nothing
no they're going to put in but I think
some a finger I think around 15 or so or
18 so what's the six
the fix is my contribution as the as the
employee okay so if you do this to find
benefit you have to put in six percent
yes okay that's mandatory
all right
and the other option is uh standard 401K
defined uh contribution
um I put in six they'll match nine
um but it's immediate there's no there's
no vesting required on that and do they
have Roth options
I don't think so it's just these two
options okay I would ask just to make
sure because my favorite is the Roth
401k
and based on what you're telling me here
I personally we answer questions you
know what would we do if we were in your
shoes today I would choose the 401K
gotcha you have way more control over
that and it doesn't the defined
benefit's gonna die when you do the 401K
you can pass on
well yeah that's that's I've been
titoing between those um as well I was
thinking exactly what you were saying um
I can I can uh control that can leave it
to someone if I wanted to
and that nine percent match that's a
really incredible
they're they're offering you a pretty
strong benefit there
and it gives you that freedom too is
this a job that you plan on being at for
10 years
uh definitely for 10 years
um uh more than that I'm not sure I mean
anything's possible uh if as long as I'm
in My Philosophy as long as I'm happy
I'll stay uh kind of mentality all right
and are you out of debt completely
I'm on uh baby step three okay good job
how far are you away from getting that
three to six months of expenses
I would say in about uh in about a year
a year to save up three to six months
that can't be
how much are you making at this new job
maybe less than that
what's your new salary
um it's gonna be around 1 30 1 30 and
what's one month of expenses of just to
cover all of your normal bills
sure
um it will be uh let me see about
4 500. okay so it's not going to take a
year let's say you even had a six month
emergency fund that's 20 grand making
130 how quickly could you save up 20 of
that if you have no debt
yeah I think I I think if I really
wanted to I think I could I could
probably do it
um uh under I think I'd probably do it
uh six months maybe on a little here we
go and what if I said hey LD you
shouldn't invest until you have that
fully funded emergency fund would that
light a fire under you to go man I'm
missing out on this match I really want
to get this emergency fund so I can get
to investing
oh
um yeah no and you'd be like I could do
this in three months actually four
months
right and so that's the power of pausing
investing and doing these steps one at a
time and so I would encourage you to do
just that to pause investing even when
you get the new job pause until you have
that fully funded emergency fund and now
that might maybe closer to three months
for you I don't know your situation I
think 10 is your bare minimum but I
would aim uh somewhere in between that
10 and 20 range to protect you against
Murphy because Murphy's gonna come
running for you when you get that new
job and you're going to have car repair
and the HVAC and all kinds of things can
happen how do you feel about that LD are
you gonna do it
yeah yeah definitely I I absolutely I
think that's a that's a good step that's
a great place to be congrats on the new
gig again I'm going with the 401K I I
think the defined benefit can look great
on paper for a lot of people Christina
but similar to a pension you have you
don't have much control over it and so
the investment gains aren't as great as
if you had control where you get to
choose all the funds and it dies with
you yeah and I mean just the 10-year
besting requirement this is a new job I
hope that it's a great job but there is
always that risk that you're not going
to stay much higher commitment level
mm-hmm yeah but I love the motivation I
love that you're excited about investing
I love the match that's very exciting
that's huge I also love the fire the
fire under you like wait I know it
sounds it's like a good coach who's
going like hey you don't get to eat that
cake until you finish the workout
because one the cake you're like I don't
know if I feel like working out today
and so you kind of when you get
comfortable you're not as willing to do
the hard things yeah so that's my
encouragement and you heard us talking
about those baby steps folks that is our
proven plan for the last 30 years 10
million people have used this to get out
of debt and when you get out of debt you
get to do your debt free scream on the
show
and all those people at some point had
to say I've had it I'm not living like
this anymore and when you get mad like
that you do what they did your life will
change too and right now inflation and
your stupid credit cards they're killing
you and you've been led to believe that
you're not in control of your money that
life just has to happen to you but
that's wrong you do have control you
have to decide to control what you can
control and that's you your behavior you
have the power to change your future and
Financial Peace University will show you
how this is the course that will teach
you our proven step-by-step plan that's
helped nearly 10 million people beat
debt Master budgeting and build wealth
and you can do it too
America stop letting debt and money
stress control your life you just have
to start with these magic words I've had
it and then Take Back Control
you can start Financial Peace University
right now at ramseysolutions.com FPU
that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU we'll be right back on the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this is your show America give us
a call Triple eight eight two five five
two two five Tampa Florida is where we
go next Dane joins us there Dane welcome
to the show
hey guys first time caller thanks for
taking my call well thank you for being
brave and calling in
thank you so I just I'm a 60 year old
um male with three children
just recently went through a real
contentious divorce um got some really
hammered hammered there
um judge really
subsided on one side
um I feel like I'm starting all over
again I'm I'm 60 years old I lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars with a
divorce I'm I'm back down to square one
almost like I'm just graduated from
college and I'm starting again but I've
been with this job for 30 years
um
every I'm living a paycheck to paycheck
everything that comes in goes right back
out with child support and insurance and
um we did overspend like my ex was 15
years my junior
um we did live beyond our means we had a
bankruptcy in the divorce
um I ended up having to pay that down
myself that was around 80 000.
um I did pay that off
um
but now I just uh I'm just not I'm not
putting anything in the bank I'm I'm
saving nothing every month oh
I'm so sorry Dane where are you at
financially today where do you stand do
you have any debt do you have money in
the bank well I have two cars uh mine
and my sons I bought my son a car and I
do have
um
about
um let's say 8
000 in credit cards
and um and that's it how much on the
cars home
um the car
um the one car I owe 15 000 and the
other car I owe um uh 25.
okay what's your income
um I was making 105 I just got a raise
I'm up to 150. and that's the other
thing I just went up but the ex found
out about it went to her attorney and
now I'm paying more child support now
because increased percentage yep oh so
she just found it yeah so I can't I
can't have any more raises I told my
boss I can't you can't give me any more
money
how old are your kids
um one's 19 just went in the Navy I was
16 year old a 17 year old who will
graduate from high school next year and
a 13 year old is the 16 year old mom
with the car loan
yes okay what's that car worth he's
killing me every yeah what's that car
worth yeah
um I owe 15. what is it worth though if
you sold it today private party Kelly
Blue Book value
I'm really not sure
um I bought it at I bought it at 19 I
owe 15. I could probably get 12. you
think you're underwater on it
uh yeah I think I think I think I am
okay do your homework on that one to
make sure my first gut move is sell the
car the 16 year old doesn't need to be
driving that nice of a car
up until about this year I was driving
cars that were a third of that cost and
so I I think we can get by and say hey
son listen life's been tough and I want
you to have a nice car and if you want
to save up and and get something I'll go
in with you on that but we can't do this
with debt going forward okay
on that one and yeah aside from monthly
payments you've got I'm the way I see it
on paper you make 150k and you have 48
in debt
so the math checks out you could pay
this debt off within the year
but the problem is right now you don't
have margin
what are your monthly expenses right now
What's the total of your outgo right now
well I just when I sold the house well
we had not much into it because like I
said we live beyond our means we spent
uh put more into the house and was worth
so got very little bit out of that
um but I rent now and I my rent is 3 200
a month oh my goodness
yeah I know I I can't stay in this place
very much in fact as soon as my son
graduates from high school next year I'm
leaving this place I can't afford that
is it a house
it's a house okay how much room do you
need
um this is a um
this was a 4-2 because I had my three
children then with me sure
um and so now when he graduates I'll go
down to a 2-2 would be just me and my
daughter
okay so you've got two kids at the house
right now
yes okay and graduation is happening
when
June of next year
okay so we got some time there and how
much are you paying a month in child
support
uh 1200.
so aside from that where where is the
150 now going
where else is the my salary go yes you
said Insurance child support what else
child support insurance for the kids
that's 1200 a month are they working
uh my son does work he just got a job
and you're talking about Auto Insurance
oh yeah my auto insurance is uh 600 a
month okay I'm wondering can the kids
start to chip in if they're working for
their own insurance and say hey you're
driving the car here's what I'm
requiring of you you pay for your
insurance you pay for your gas you pay
for your maintenance
I told him he just has to start paying
for his gas okay they just started doing
that now
so other than that are you are you doing
a monthly budget I know life's been nuts
for you no no I haven't okay I'm gonna
help you with that and gift you one year
of every dollar premium and what I want
you to do you have a great income and
right now it feels like it's just
disappearing into the abyss right
right but when you can make a plan on
paper and you list out you know I'm
assuming your take-home pay is somewhere
is 150 gross and so take home pays close
to nine or so Grand a month
um that's correct okay are you investing
right now
um I do I think I'm putting in about
um
let's see 500 a month into my um 401K
okay we're gonna pause that for a short
period of time so that we have some
margin to clean up this debt and you're
going to be back to investing in no time
I know you're 60 you're going well I
gotta retire too man but it's hard when
you can't even get out of the cycle so
if you're willing to do that pause
investing go through make a budget list
your income at the top then you're gonna
list all of your expenses and as you
look at it you're gonna go man I need a
creative way to lower this bill is this
one of the kids bills can I see if they
can chip in there am I overpaying for
insurance I'm gonna go shop with Xander
across all of my insurance premiums you
know what I can cut the subscription for
now I'm not going to eat out because
wheat right now we have forty eight
thousand dollars to tackle and I'm gonna
do whatever it takes to put myself on a
financial Foundation as I start this new
chapter of my life that I did not ask
for but it's where we find ourselves
well you may also have to have some real
conversations with the kids be really
honest about where you are financially
and just you know let them know like
George said earlier that they probably
need to contribute a bit more and also
with the rent I would encourage you I
know that you're waiting until one of
the kids is out of the house but just
shop around and see if you can find
something cheaper and mean I know it's
tough because yeah having kids you want
a little bit of space but that's a
pretty big outgo monthly and if you
could find even
yeah I definitely want to get out of
that house but I wanted to stay there
until my son graduates in June so I
really need to do that because it's
right close to the high school so I need
to I need I need to really stay there so
I'll when is the Lisa
I go month to month right now so anytime
I can I can bail but I'd still look
around you said you're in a 4-2 could
you go down to a three and now we get
the rent down to 2500 and so I still
want you to do your homework on that and
if it's if I gotta move again when my
daughter when my son graduates then I
gotta move again I understand moving is
not fun but if it means we're going to
get out of debt six months faster
it's worth the headache how is your
landlord do you have a pretty good
relationship with the landlord because
I'm wondering if there's is there any
chance that you could do a six-month
lease through the end of June and see if
he can give you a little bit better of a
rate say you know I'm guaranteeing I'll
be here for this amount of time and uh
in in exchange for that could you give
me a little bit lower monthly payment
that's a good move so Dane here's what
we're going to do I'm going to gift you
one year of every dollar premium I want
you to create your monthly budget track
it stick to it try to shave down all the
expenses try to add in as much as you
can on the income side and we're going
to gift you one year of Financial Peace
University as well watch all nine
lessons to motivate you and realize that
it's not too late for you I know you're
60 and you're starting this weird new
chapter of your life but you can do this
man it may not be what you hoped for
pictured but this is where we find
ourselves when we can move forward we
can still have a great retirement we can
still raise some great kids and also go
to ramseysolutions.com and search for
divorce checklists we've got some great
info from there from Dr John deloney
that covers a lot of the financial
pieces for you to think about make sure
all of your eyes are dotted T's are
crossed
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis it's
a free call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Matthew is up
next in Virginia Beach Virginia Matthew
welcome to the show
hey thanks so much
um appreciate everyone's help and um
my quick synopsis of uh where I am my
wife and I have two uh leased vehicles
right now one is not going to be done
for a couple of years it's still like 30
months out from being expired
um and the lease payments very low so
we're happy with it the second one is
coming off in uh April and the buyout is
around twenty five thousand dollars
which we put aside and we have but we're
now thinking like do we really need to
use twenty five thousand dollar car even
though it has very low miles on it so
we're trying to figure out like you know
what's the best thing to do here should
we wait until you know the dealership
says okay do you want to buy it do you
want to lease it or do you want to
extend the lease or whatever you want to
do with it
um do we just hand it back look for a
car that's you know let's say ten
thousand dollars cheaper and take the
money and put it to other you know needs
that we have in our life or because the
car has so few miles on it relatively
speaking
um and the cost of cars keeps going we
just keep it and say look you know it's
a long term we're gonna this is
something we're gonna hold on to and
we've taken the payment away what's your
financial system yeah what's your
financial situation right now do you
have any debt
so we don't have any other debt other
than that we have uh our
um five to six months of emergency fund
um we we are into a pretty large
mortgage that wasn't originally a 30 and
we're putting an extra principal payment
every month in to try and get it down to
15
um
years
um we've got most of the monies that
we've kind of said to our children that
we were going to put aside for college
um and we have steady jobs so really
it's just kind of the last little hurdle
is getting rid of the car payments
um and then we can really you know have
that free up money to throw more at the
mortgage or our retirement so are you
are you done with leasing cars
I'm done with leasing cars I mean listen
we you know I've always been a Ramsey
listener and then
um during covert we kind of reshuffled
our life and moved and and when we did
all of this we really realized like we
were just completely mismanaging so much
of the gifts that we have and and the
you know the economic Gifts of being
employed and healthy okay and and we
realized we've got to we've got to get
out of this gig okay good what's your
household income
160. all right
and how much do you have in cash in the
bank between all the bank accounts
liquid cash
say that again I'm sorry how much do you
have in cash across your bank accounts
oh
um arcs so our emergency fund has about
50 000 in it and then we have this other
25 that we put aside to kind of buy one
of the leases figuring which one you
know we were going to buy what's the
other early buyout on the other lease
you said to sell us a few more years
left
it's going to be more than this one it's
the this one is about 25 000 the other
one is because it's further out
um it's closer to 27. okay so why don't
we just go ahead and do early buyout on
both
and we pay the 52 then we can sell both
cars if you don't like one of them sell
them but you guys have the money to do
it you have the income to do it it makes
you completely debt free today
yeah why not just do that instead of
continuing this thing
right right and so with an early buyout
I mean they don't give you any type of a
break I mean you you're basically
whatever's left on the on the lease they
add to whatever was was you know decided
upon when you leased it correct there's
no leverage that you have at all I'm not
sure that the terms you sign but it's
worth looking into to see if you can get
out of this thing even if you pay the
stupid tax on it because you're going to
pay more continuing the lease
yeah for years
so I'm not going to choose to stay in
debt for years because I got a bad deal
this is part of what we call stupid tax
and you learn from it and you go never
again am I going to lease a car we call
it a fleece around here because it's the
most expensive way to operate a vehicle
and it makes the dealerships really rich
and you really broke all the while they
convince you that this is the wisest
thing to do and it's so great because
you don't have to worry about
maintenance and my it's a nightmare and
you know that now right on the car
that's coming up with the lease ending
do you like that car
you know it's a solid car
um it's a it's a Arcadia you know it's a
it's a GMC Acadia it's a nice car got
less than 30 000 miles on it but we're
not in love with it no and and we don't
necessarily need you know to have that
big of a car or that you know to spend
25 000 on it so yeah looking at it and
saying you know how do we how do we do
this differently that
I'm wondering is I mean if you don't
like the car 25 000 can buy you another
nice car so I would probably shop around
to see you know what can I get for 25k
or less like you said you may not need
that much car and you could have someone
in the bank so here's what I'm Matthew
if I'm in your shoes I'm going to do the
early buyout on both pay the stupid tax
be done with this debt it's gonna cost
you 52 Grand which you have in the bank
you said you had 75 and once you do that
you can sell both of them and buy
reasonable cars with cash no more loans
no more debt and then we're free and
clear and if you need to restock your
emergency fund from there that's great
but right now we're in debt payoff mode
get cars now we can start doing the
steps because you're doing 17 things at
once you're trying to throw extra on the
mortgage we've got the emergency fund
we're trying to pay off the debt and
when that happens you can't make the
progress you're looking for and you get
frustrated so that's what I would do get
out of debt as quickly as possible good
news is you guys have the money in the
bank and you have a fantastic income and
what we say around cars is everything
with a motor and it should not add up to
more than 50 percent of your income and
you guys are in that parameter so you
can buy twenty five thousand dollar cars
that you love instead of being in this
lease and do it with cash so that's our
that's our advice we're sticking to it
Tanya's up next in Idaho all right Tanya
what do you got for us how's it going
sure
and this is in addition to
um having two full-time jobs wow and
immediately it was something that I did
not want to do I wanted to back out well
we still had the illegal right to do so
in the inspection and feasibility study
process
but I went along with the vision and we
have been in the red ever since we
opened my husband has now lost his job
and just cashed out part of his 401k to
keep the business floating on a in
that's in addition to another 20 000
line of credit twenty thousand dollars
in a credit card to keep the business
open and of course this has caused
division within our marriage and we are
now looking at one of three
possibilities one accepting a lowball
offer on the business where we would
still have to come up with another
thirty to fifty thousand dollars cash to
be able to walk away from it
two
shut the doors try and make the payment
on the loan and the building out of our
income
or three try and work with someone else
that might be able to take the business
to the next level maybe more product and
services offered through the restaurant
and keep it going and maybe get some
income that way
so this is a restaurant right
it's a bakery Coffee House currently the
third option would we would bring in
someone we know who's been a cook their
whole life and has run restaurants and
maybe add more to it which would also
mean putting in additional commercial
kitchen equipment which sounds like more
than Friars which sounds like more debt
so we're not doing that anything that
involves continuing the bleeding we are
just taking off the table
and that means we're getting creative
we're going to be Scrappy we're going to
move slow uh I'm not going to tell you
you should or shouldn't file bankruptcy
I don't know enough about your business
that's something you should contact a
bankruptcy attorney for
but what I can tell you is that there's
other ways there is hope but it starts
with saying we're not going to do it
with debt because clearly that's going
to only hurt our chances of getting out
of this thing of surviving
so your husband lost his job what was he
doing
um he worked as a corporate
investigations officer so everything
from espion knowledge at a corporate
level to trusted violence at work that
sort of thing wow okay well step one we
need to get him back to work and see if
you can start to cash flow some of this
from your other full-time jobs this may
mean 70-hour weeks bringing the other
person in giving them Equity because we
can't pay a lot right now doing whatever
it takes before I'm throwing in the
towel and filing bankruptcy which will
follow you forever and it's going to be
a nightmare to go through that I don't
want that for you guys there could be a
way out and so investigate this do your
homework and please know more dead this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money
Josh is up next and San Antonio Josh
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Georgia Christina thanks for taking
my call I appreciate it absolutely how's
it going
um my dad is uh into Windham uh
timeshare rewards and he's looking to
add me and my four siblings on as like
co-owners or being able to use it all
and so we would all split the time and
split the points and share it all and it
all sounds great but and split the cost
exactly and my two my two oldest sisters
all don't get along either so I'm not
looking forward to getting into
something with all of them where we
would all have to share it and
communicate and pay the fees and you
know but it'll pay for itself so I just
don't know how to go about telling him
that money and my wife are not
interested when all my other siblings
are
um gosh it's so hard because I my mom
used to love to go to the timeshare
presentations and get the like free
tickets to Disney World and I remember
sitting through them and they really
sell this idea of Legacy they make it
sound like oh this is something that you
can pass down to generations and you'll
be so excited to give it to your kids
and your kids are going to be excited I
did and that's just not the reality no
and exactly so he's been doing this for
like 25 years and trying to he's really
been looking forward to it and that's
kind of the build up and um we had a
little bit of hinting that we don't want
in on it but um I basically need to tell
him that we're totally out and uh I
don't know really how to break it to us
yeah does he love does he love the
program is he like a mega fan or do you
think that there's any inkling that he
wants out
no he's a mega fan
well you don't have to be and I know
this is easier said than done but
there's these two letters they make up
one word and that is no if you want to
be really nice you can say no thank you
and that's it I mean at the end of the
day he can't force you into this and if
this is what's going to cause a rift in
the relationship
then so be it if this is what his line
is of saying Josh if you're not going to
join the timeshare then I'm not going to
talk to you anymore do you think it's
going to be that level of animosity no
no I don't think it's going to be that
little of a mouse to be we've also just
kind of talked about like hey do we just
kind of like pacify it and basically do
it but then not use it and just kind of
let my siblings use it no there's no if
you jump into it you're stuck with the
costs forever
right right well a lot of times if you
do the math it's not it doesn't work out
well for you like never works out I've
sat down with my mom and talked through
the math and I used to love sitting in
the timeshare presentations with her
because one she's tough as nails and has
no problem telling people no and two it
kind of prepped me for this job because
I would just go through the numbers and
write them down and they'd be like look
at these numbers you're going to save so
much and it's like when you really break
out the math you don't
and so I mean I even wonder if you kind
of approach it a little bit from a
numbers perspective and even like a
comparison perspective of Our Generation
I think we kind of see vacation a bit
different there's so many different
alternative options by the time you add
up all the fees for these time shares
you could get an Airbnb that's got three
bedrooms for like a lot cheaper it makes
you want to throw up when you do the
math Josh and you go all right what is
this costing us here okay it's costing
us six thousand dollars what would we do
with six grand well we can book some
pretty sweet hotels for a week for sixth
grade we can get some airbnbs we can do
a lot of things we can take multiple
trips and go where we want instead of
hope that it's on the Wyndham you know
point system move it around and not
there's no blackout dates and so I mean
the conversation is the hardest part
here I think you know in your heart
we're not doing this and so you know
your dad better than we do of how you're
going to approach this in a respectful
way and I I strug sometimes I talk to my
dad and I'm like listen I don't agree
with this financial decision and I have
to just end it and say I love you too
much to continue in this argument we're
going to stop it here and so yeah you
can hit him with all the stats I mean
you can say hey this is expensive this
has no investment value it's not an
asset I don't own anything the
maintenance costs are going to rise four
percent annually say we don't have the
money we have priorities in life and
owning a timeshare isn't one of them I'd
rather own actual real estate instead of
this essentially this metaverse level a
sense of ownership like I don't do nfts
and I don't do time shares for the same
reason I want actual ownership not a
sense of ownership well and the fact
that he's a mega fan like maybe you can
even just like you're not trying to
convince him to sell it at this point it
doesn't sound like he's willing to do
that but maybe even the the assurance
that hey we'll still go on vacation with
you like if you if you want us to come
along for your timeshare like we'll
still go with you we just don't want to
be owners-wise we don't want this for us
right that makes that makes a lot of
sense and I think approaching it from we
have different goals and we definitely
want to own real estate known vacation
properties and things like that but yeah
I want to actually own it I don't want
to force vacation fees for about 7 500 a
month or 7 500 a year so I think you
nailed around the head bro snow thanks
Josh good luck with the conversation man
and here's the other thing that could
convince him go to eBay and search
timeshare and go to completed and sold
listings and then rate it from lowest to
highest price you will see timeshares
that sold for a dollar legit that's how
badly people want to get rid of these
things they are just selling them for a
dollar because you know it doesn't
actually cost a dollar it costs eight
thousand dollars a year and that goes up
four percent every year with headaches
so good luck with that man gosh I hate
timeshares oh yeah the worst it's it's
such a slimy I hope once like gen Z
takes over we're just done with time
shares I'm sure they'll come up with
other stupid decisions but I'm I hope
time shares will be like dinosaurs
they'll just be gone no one will do them
anymore it's like cigarettes we know
it's not cool I think there's already
plenty of stupid decisions out in the
market but that is true maybe this one
will be gone one less one out there all
right Joseph's up next in Orange County
California Joseph welcome to the show
hello thank you guys for having me I
appreciate uh you guys taking time out
of your day to go ahead and help me out
yeah what's going on
um so I'm 22 years old I just recently
got a new career
um I'm kind of jumping in terms of how
much money I'm making now so for a
little context the last four years I
have kind of just been working part-time
jobs really trying to get into the
career that I just got into so I went
from making uh ten thousand dollars a
year to now having a starting salary of
around eighty thousand dollars
yeah and uh other people in um my field
at the position I'm at are making a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars with
overtime so I'm just honestly a little
bit overwhelmed because I haven't really
been the best at budgeting money due to
the fact that I haven't had a lot coming
in and now I have a decent I know in
California uh 100K doesn't really go too
far but it's a huge jump for me so I'm
trying to figure out now how I should be
trying to
um you know build my portfolios or how
to start putting money aside so that you
know I can be successful and have a lot
of money in the future for myself the
career that I have does provide a full
pension uh full health benefits so I've
just been asking around and I'm just
really stuck on if I should be trying to
get save money for Real Estate putting
money into a Roth IRA I just honestly
have no idea how to start we're up
against the clock here so this is going
to be like lightning round so you're
making 80k how much debt do you have
I have no debt right now fantastic how
much money do you have in the bank
uh I have five thousand dollars in the
bank but I also have um twenty five
thousand dollars that was left to me as
an inheritance um that I haven't touched
um so I have that as well awesome so on
that side get with a smartvestor pro
figure out if there's any tax
implications but that could kind of
catapult you to where you have a fully
funded emergency fund now we can start
investing and is the pension the only
option you have is there a 401k as well
or just pension
the option for a 401 1K my company does
match up to twenty thousand dollars a
year awesome that's amazing so I might
look into that option so that you
actually own this you have more control
over it it doesn't die with you like the
pension I don't know if it's an either
or situation but look into that and as
far as the budgeting side I love you of
the self-awareness to go like I know I
haven't been great budgeting and I want
to be great and so we can help you with
that by gifting you one year of every
dollar premium which is our app it's a
website you can go in and track all of
that and with the premium version it'll
connect to your bank and you can just
drag transactions in and that way you'll
have a plan for every dollar but right
now it sounds like we want to get
started investing once we have three to
six months of expenses and beyond that
it's hey can we save up a down payment
on a house can we upgrade the car all of
those things so do you have those goals
in mind
yes definitely I definitely want to uh
be a property owner that's always been a
goal of mine awesome well it's going to
be a lot closer man making this kind of
money good for you 22 making 80k golly I
love it we love to see it but wishing
you the best Joseph hang on the line
Jenna's gonna pick up we're going to
gift you every dollar premium let's go
ahead and throw in Financial Peace
University that will give you the full
plan since we ran out of time here of
how you're going to do that how to buy
real estate wisely that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show in the books my
thanks to Christina Ellis and all the
folks in the booth Jenna and Ben and
Austin and Andrew and Josh and you
America we appreciate you listening
we'll be back with you before you know
it
[Music]
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Christina Ellis
joined by my co-host George Campbell
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're answering
your questions about your life and your
money and we'd love to chat with you so
give us a call first up we have David
calling from Seattle Washington hey
David welcome to the show
hey Christina hey George it's a pleasure
talking to you guys good talking to you
too how can we help
um I guess so I have a I've saved up
quite a bit of money
um at least quite a bit for me
um and I'm trying to figure out what to
do with it uh just to give you a quick
background I have I guess nineteen
thousand dollars in student loans and
um I guess with the whole student loan
forgiveness thing I'm just kind of
confused as to what to do right now
welcome to the party my friend
a lot of people are refusing times out
there and student loan forgiveness world
yep so what what exactly is your
question
um yeah I just I get I have fifty
thousand dollars saved up uh just kind
of just being Frugal I guess uh with my
wife and I my wife's in the military
good for you um awesome yeah so we're
I have the ability to pay it off but I
don't know if like right now is the time
and then we're also thinking like once
she's out of the military we want to buy
a house and so we're kind of like
pondering out what to do with the excess
like should it just stay in the savings
account where it's at or put it in like
some sort of investment account
do you all have any other debt
uh no okay is that your emergency fund
and that 50k as well uh yeah so about I
guess nine to twelve of that would be an
emergency fund okay what's your income
um so to get together I I make 90 my
wife makes about 36 something like that
uh so 120 base I guess great
Man David it's just it's a tricky time
right now with student loan forgiveness
so there's a lot of opinions out there
um a lot of lawsuits out there and a lot
of people really excited about
forgiveness and we're kind of in this
month where it's make or break we're
gonna see some movement hopefully one
way or another and if we don't see
movement then that's concerning so where
it's at right now they said the
applications for forgiveness were going
to be available at the beginning of the
month and then they said it was going to
be the 17th and now they're saying the
24th so it seems like it keeps getting
pushed back they did release a preview
of the application
um and I don't I don't know how I feel
about that because it kind of feels a
little bit like dangling the carrot to
say hey it's still here it feels like a
movie studio and the movie's not done
like just put put a trailer out there
just buy some time man yeah so I mean
it's it's a strange time I mean I I feel
like by the end of the month the end of
October we should have some clarity in
some direction a lot of the lawsuits out
there there are some that have some tea
that was reading this morning that a
federal judge is trying to block it one
state and there's several I think
there's six states that are in on the
lawsuit so there's just a lot of
movement this month so if it were me and
I don't know correct me if I'm wrong
George but I would probably wait to the
end of the month just to see what
happens I mean we're only weeks away
from seeing decisions and a little bit
more clarity I'm not exactly holding my
breath that it's going to happen because
a lot could change in the next month I
mean there's a lot of people who don't
think forgiveness is going to happen at
all
um and so it's just it's a really tricky
time but I would give it maybe a few
weeks just to see if these applications
actually come out and if and if not then
it's great that you have the money to
pay it off I love that if student loan
forgiveness ends up not happening for
whatever reason that you could take that
money right now and wipe out those
student loans
right no that was that was kind of the
plan are those your student loans hers
who's who's it yeah they're they're mine
so best case you would get 10K forgiven
uh uh well
we're married so uh I think it would be
9 the full 19 or 20 I guess I had like
30 or I had 30 originally but I paid off
I guess but they're not her loans it's
not 10 000 per person it's per borrower
did you have a Pell Grant when you were
in college I I did yeah okay so just on
your own regardless of being married you
would qualify for that if it was Pilgrim
right so Christina correct me if I'm
wrong if he paid it off today
he could still qualify to get
forgiveness if it comes down the road
well and they're they're doing the
refund where if you think you'll get a
refund during the pause you could apply
for the refund and then get it forgiven
so yeah I mean if you want to wait the
two weeks and see if anything happens
I'm personally not holding my breath uh
if I'm in your shoes I feel good about
paying it off you get 50k in the bank
let's call 15 your emergency fund that
makes me feel better with your income
and expenses that leaves you 35. you pay
off the 19 that still leaves you with
16. now you're completely debt free you
have a fully funded emergency fund you
have 16 000 in the bank now is the time
we can start saving on top of that for
the down payment
right
um yeah and we're so just in quick point
to that uh we're not planning on I guess
buying for a while uh just because like
the just being in the military uh and
that kind of thing yeah
um but I we definitely have the option
to so we just didn't know like if it's
best to put it in like a savings account
or should we look more is this like
three years out or is this like seven
years out it's actually it's like right
on three years okay if it's three years
or less I would stick to a high yield
savings account online right now you can
get over two percent sometimes over
three percent with bonuses
um and that money can grow at least for
you but the point of this is not to grow
at you know nine ten percent because as
you've seen the stock market's been a
little crazy lately and so people that
two years ago said I'm gonna put my
house down payment in the stock market
and two years from now it's gonna grow
so much and I'm gonna get a house well
now they're crying because their
accounts are down 25 and so it worries
me when you have a short time Horizon to
throw the money into the market if it's
you know five plus years I feel better
about that because over that period of
time the money
um you know historically will have grown
yeah how do you think what's your advice
for people trying to figure out the best
high yield savings account where should
people put their money so there's a lot
of there's tons of online banks these
days but I look at ones that have a
long-term track record always make sure
it's FDIC which means it's insured by
the government in case the bank goes
bankrupt your money's secure up to 250
000 per uh depositor on the account so
if you're married it's a joint account
you have up to five hundred thousand and
so most of the banks do that but you
just want to be careful because some of
these will promise big interest numbers
but they might be temporary so I've I've
had good experiences with Ally and with
Marcus by Goldman Sachs as good solid
high-yield savings account options now
some of these best high yield savings
account options they're online banks and
I know some people can feel kind of
nervous about that what would you say to
kind of alleviate fear around that
that's where it goes us back to the
proven track record how long has have
these people been around allies been
around forever Marcus is a Goldman Sachs
company it's been around forever it's
FDIC insured so I don't see it any
different as your your local bank
security level and so obviously you want
to have good fraud protection and
password security and you know
multi-factor authentication and some
things to protect your password but
other than that it's no different than
having your your debit card associated
with your checking account so this is a
great option be careful though because
some of these online banks you can't
wire money out if you're trying to close
on your home so you want to make sure
you have a good month window of time to
get the money out to your checking
account with your local bank to do any
kind of home purchasing it's a good word
George we're taking your calls Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll be right back this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from Milwaukee Wisconsin
hey Kenzie welcome to the show
hey how are you guys we're doing great
thanks for calling how can we help
yeah thanks for taking my calls so my
question is regarding
um paint off her house my husband and I
bought a house about a month and a half
ago we did a 30-year mortgage
um this was before I started listening
to you guys so I know you would probably
poo poo that
um but we're just trying to figure out a
plan of how we can pay it off as quick
as we can just taking a peek at our
budget and trying to find some areas
where we could cut back on in particular
one area that we're looking at is
investing so we both invest 15 of our
income and I don't know if we're
investing too much if we should be
investing 15
combined or individual
great great questions Kenzie so yes you
both want to invest 15 because that's 15
of your total household income by the
end of the year
okay so out of all the areas to cut I
would not cut investing you guys are
doing so great in that area and when we
talk about baby step four five six we do
those at the same time so you got 15 you
guys have kids
you don't okay so we are fast passing
through baby step five now we're baby
step six you guys have no debt other
than the house no that just the holidays
wonderful in a fully funded emergency
fund
fully funded this is the place to be
okay so how much margin do you guys have
right now while investing 15 what is
left at the end of the month to throw
extra on top of the principal
yeah so we have probably about like
three grand so we think we can probably
throw like at least 1500 Extra a month
at it you have an extra three grand on
top of being able to pay your mortgage
correct so why not throw the whole three
grand do you have other things you're
trying to save up for
under this house we have stuff to buy
for it so trying to kind of budget out
like things you want to buy for the
house and otherwise we don't really have
like many other expenses we have a
travel fund they try to throw money into
a travel fund so we can take trips um
here and there but
no I guess just trying to figure out
like what's a good amount to save
um I mean we have a savings right now
with probably like 25 Grand in it and I
don't know if we should just take from
that and maybe throw some of that at the
mortgage too well if that's beyond your
goal for your emergency fund let's say
your emergency fund goal is for four or
five months and that adds up to 20 grand
that means that extra five we can now
use for these kind of house projects
renovations
I like separating the emergency fund
because all of a sudden the sale at the
mall turns into an emergency and so
keeping it separate and going is this
unexpected is this urgent is this
necessary that qualifies as a true
emergency me wanting to wallpaper the
bathroom this weekend this is a personal
uh attack on my wife that is not a true
emergency you know and so we're going to
save up for that separately and you can
do that with a sinking fund line item in
your budget so you could say hey house
repairs and projects I'm going to put
200 every month into that fund so that
by the end of the year we have 2400 we
can spend
What's the total mortgage you all have
right now
so the total mortgage is 2500 a month
that's including taxes two in there
what's the loan amount
e89 okay and what's your household
income
you probably make about like 140 I would
say around there okay so your take-home
pay is probably I'm guessing eight or
nine grand what does that come out to
probably closer to eight I think it ends
up I think it ends up being closer to
like seven okay because you're investing
before that hits your bank account
correct okay so one I mean you're you
guys are doing great to still have three
grand of margin but that mortgage is 35
of your income every month and that's on
a 30 year
right and so you guys bought a whole lot
of house comparatively to your income
and down payment levels which you'll
survive you know you're in a good spot
financially but I'm with you I don't
want to have have this debt any longer
than I have to and so if we can pay it
off faster than 15 years uh that's the
goal so we have a great mortgage payoff
calculator at ramseysolutions.com go
jump onto that you can click on free
tools and you can enter in your loan
amount enter in your date of your first
payment enter in the loan link which is
for you guys is 30 years and the
interest rate and that add-on how much
extra you're going to put and that will
start to give you a picture of oh my
gosh if we could find another 400 we can
pay this off three years faster how cool
would that be
well George you you have experience with
this personally you paid off your house
early yes we did this December 2021 and
we did it at free scream this past
January and that was part of the game to
us which where I guess we're just sick
people but we were like always doing the
calculations yeah like we can put
another 400 bucks towards this that
speeds It Up by this much and this much
so I love having a goal saying Hey what
if we could pay it off in the next eight
years and then try to beat that goal
over time and you meet the people on the
stage everyone's debt-free Journey tends
to go faster once they get into it
because it's addictive and they're
willing to sacrifice more and more as
they get closer well I think that's a
huge key is having that clear goal and
having something to push towards because
if not it is easy to go you know what I
think I want that extra throw pillow I
want that extra you know piece of
furniture but if you've got that clear
goal you've got a timeline you've got
something that you're really charging
towards I think it just makes you that
much more motivated oh absolutely and I
speak on behalf of all guys and say we
don't need any more throw pillows we
don't need any more shams which is a
great name because that thing is a sham
and you can't even sleep on it you get
yelled at
all right our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out yourself
whyblinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promo codes they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Andy in Tennessee he
asks if we say for 18 years in a 529
plan and our daughter doesn't use it for
Education what can we do with that money
that is a great question so many people
are worried about investing because
they're going what if my what if my kid
doesn't go to college Christina right I
don't know what's going to happen I
don't know how expensive I'm just not
going to invest
that's not that's not the great the best
option because I'm just giving I'm just
making the impression here well there
are a lot of different options that you
have with a 529 if your student doesn't
end up using that money so for starters
you could transfer it to another
beneficiary so if there's a sibling
coming up that's going to need to go to
college you can transfer that money to
them you can also transfer it to other
family members so a niece or a nephew
um it's very generous it's very
permissible family members you can do
spouse child grandchild siblings parents
step parents nephews nieces Aunts Uncles
and even first cousins yeah I don't
think people realize how far out that
goes so there's a lot of options
um you can also save that money for
future educational needs so maybe your
student isn't going to college right now
maybe they don't want a four-year
education right now but maybe in five
years they go hey I changed my mind I
want to go back and get a certificate I
want to go to trade school or even if
they are in college and they didn't use
all that money they could go to grad
school so that money could get used
later on and then you can also save it
for a grandchild so let's say your kid
doesn't go to school maybe that's an
educational Legacy that you leave for
your family later on and I would just
make sure to highlight with that to talk
to a taxpro because there are some
implications with skipping Generations
but you can still set it up in a way
where that that fund is available for
future children yeah and then also a
really cool thing is they have um
penalty free scholarship withdrawals I
love this a lot of people don't know
about this a lot of people don't know
about this so check out that because you
can use that money without some of the
so they can see some challenges if I get
a ten thousand dollar scholarship then
the 529 plan was a waste no you can
withdraw ten thousand dollars from the
account to your bank account against
that scholarship with no penalties it's
amazing exactly so it also encourages
you to still pursue scholarships
aggressively I think some people who
have 529 plans are like hey we've
already saved out of this money my kid
doesn't really need scholarships we'll
still go for the scholarships because if
they get those scholarships that money
can go to something else they can go to
their wedding a down payment on a house
or or something in the future so still
keep the motivation for both and
remember if you start investing you know
there's in this example from age zero to
eighteen and you just put two grand a
year in that thing that's 36 000 over 18
years well the growth on that account it
could grow up to a hundred thousand
dollars which means the majority of the
money in that account was all growth
that's amazing yeah and even if you only
have twenty five dollars to invest I
think we took a call a few weeks ago
where somebody was like oh I only have
this tiny bit is it even worth it yes 25
a month is way better than nothing so
you know especially with the power of
compound interest exactly well we're
taking your calls Triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
right now is the time of year when it's
make or break when it comes to our goals
we're heading into holiday season and
let's be real it's hard to stay
motivated we all have goals whether it's
to find a better job make more money pay
off debt build stronger relationships
and it can be hard to keep momentum
going but here's the good news coming up
in a couple weeks we have one of our
biggest events smart conference we're
headed to Dallas for a day-long
jam-packed event where you'll get advice
from leading experts on money personal
growth career mental health and your
marriage you'll leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life you
want join me and the rest of our Ramsay
personalities Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman and George Campbell
and Rachel Cruz to get a plan for your
money your relationships personal growth
and career join us live in person on
October 22nd to get your passes before
they sell out visit ramseysolutions.com
events to get your tickets today just
almost a week away how crazy is that so
it's gonna be a good time live band
highly entertaining I did my rehearsal
yesterday oh I'm excited so I'm feeling
good about it it should be a good time
and if you if you're not in Dallas I
want you to know that people travel from
all over the country to join us for this
event and it is so worth the drive the
flight whatever you got to do bring the
whole family it's going to be a good
time it's going to be so fun all right
up next we have Tyson calling from Idaho
Falls Idaho hey Tyson welcome to the
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it hey thanks for calling how
can we help
hey so first thing I just want to wish
my wife a happy birthday it's her
birthday today
happy birthday
my question has to deal with um
errors
Steve from
company
they're not to count that as part of my
15 going into retirement
hmm great question so how much do you
have
as far as shares yeah
right now
um it's valued at about 30 000. okay
I would not count that as part of your
15 but I love that you have them how are
you fully vested could you you know cash
out today
as far as cashing out I don't believe so
um I think the only way you can redeem
those shares is uh leaving the company
there is an option to roll them into
what's called a an ESOP 401k
to my understanding
um
okay but I I'm not sure if there's if
there's a way I can actually cache that
and roll them into like a traditional
IRA okay yeah do your homework on that
uh I personally I some of these programs
can can be great because you're getting
stocks at a discount but if you're not
cashing them out immediately to kind of
get your most return on that it worries
me because of the volatility obviously
you work at this company so you believe
in it but single stocks in general are
way too volatile for me to be putting my
money in and so from a just thirty
thousand foot view I go oh boy this this
worries me so I wouldn't count it part
is your 15 do you have any other
retirement options there like a
traditional 401K Roth 401k
oh sorry you left the line there let's
even get him back are you still with us
there
oh it's on here oh okay so do you have a
401k as well
yes I currently contribute 15 to a Roth
401k as well oh perfect I would continue
doing that and then are these shares is
it mandatory how does the ESOP work for
you are you putting extra additional
money into that to buy the stocks at a
discount
no so basically as the company is
profitable
um certain amount of shares are given to
each employee based off uh how well the
company oh right so it's like a bonus
kind of a profit sharing situation
yeah so it's kind of like a company
match type of thing but I don't know if
that was different from a 401k match to
an ESOP uh chair yeah I just keep doing
what you're doing 15 to that Roth 401k
and I see this as icing on the cake this
is gravy when you leave you got a big
pile of cash from these stocks and I
would cash out as soon as you're able to
and that way you have more control over
it you can put that in good growth stock
mutual funds index funds and it's way
more Diversified way less risk thanks
for the call yeah up next we have Noel
calling from Knoxville Tennessee hey
Noelle welcome to the show
thanks for having me guys I'll try to be
as clear as I can and please questions
at any time my mother passed away
earlier this year uh leaving my disabled
52 year old brother who is on disability
without a home and with no inheritance
to care for him how can I and my other
brother best try to care for him
financially moving forward and possibly
set him up for better care
um I'm so sorry to hear about your mom
and the the situation with your brother
you're now left dealing with
yeah
so how old are you
thanks and I have another brother that
is 47 and this brother is 52. so he was
currently living with my mother and was
a dependent on her and uh she actually
put the house into a trust which is
supposed to be sold and distributed
amongst other beneficiaries so he does
not have a home at this time
but anything that she had left over she
distributed it completely to others in
inheritance what do you mean to others
other family members things like that so
basically those that will benefit from
the sale of the house and the trust
would be like the eight grandchildren
um other money that she might have had
in retirement will go to uh possibly a
sister on these things like that was
anything left to your brother
nothing nothing was left to my brother
myself or my other brother at this time
did your mother talk to you about that
and why she set it up that way
she did not no so is this a surprise to
you when she passed and they went that's
weird they skipped us
it was to everybody and we've tried
working with someone to kind of figure
out if there was something that was done
um improperly if I could say that in a
nice way and and there's nothing we can
do at this point so now moving forward
we just have to start taking care of
things and making sure that he has the
care that he has in the future and he is
on a fixed income okay what is his
income
1100 I'm
all right and disability and possibly uh
Social Security where is he now where is
he living
um so right now he is currently uh
living in the home before it is to be
sold and then we're kind of going all
right what's next we gotta get him some
housing
correct we currently um are have opened
both of our houses my brother and myself
he lives in Michigan and I live in
Tennessee Okay so that is an option
we're looking more medically how we can
take care of his medical needs moving
forward I know probably a strict budget
of his
um disability income definitely is a
must I was thinking possibly looking
into the long-term care insurance but I
do not know that he's going to qualify
because he does have some some current
disability
um yeah I would reach out to our friends
at Xander to at least see what the
options are because of his disability
and see what he would qualify for to
help out the situation so in terms of
housing he can live with one of y'all
long term right
you can't that is correct we'll probably
have to modify our homes slightly uh
things like that
um so he can but I guess and he does
have he does have
um Medicare but we do know that that's
probably not the best
um in the long run nursing homes care
things like that so that's why we wanted
to kind of look into what can we do now
in the future to possibly get you know a
little bit more maybe in-home care if
needed how could we possibly go about
doing that now saving up beside the
possible long-term and care insurance
yeah what other options if anybody knows
does he need full-time care what's that
situation like not at this moment he
does not but uh it's something where his
body is deteriorating
um as the days go on so it's something
that's definitely going to be in the
future how soon that we don't know that
we do we do not know Well for now let's
let's get this house situation figured
out correct and get that thing sold then
have him move in with one of you
whatever makes more sense temporarily
while we do our research do our homework
look into the different insurance plans
talk to our friends at Xander and figure
out what's the most affordable option to
get him the care he needs right now if
he needs more then later on down the
road we do more homework and figure out
how we do that later on but you guys
getting in a financial position between
you and the brother talking about this
how are we going to handle this
financially logistically making a plan
for all of that that's the best thing
you can do right now for him but I'm so
sorry you're putting the situation
that's a tough place to be but you sound
like a great sister for sure
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day is do not judge
others and you will not be judged for
you will be treated as you treat others
the standard you use in judging is the
standard by which you will be judged
Matthew 7 1-2
their quote of the day is those who
judge will never understand and those
who understand will never judge Wilson
kandini
welcome back to the Ramsey show this is
Christina Ellis George joined by George
camel up next we have Matthias calling
from Fort Lauderdale Florida hey welcome
to the show
all right thank you for taking my call
Christina and George how are you thanks
for calling we're great how can we help
so I'm a long time listener and a
first-time caller I decided today to
answer George's call to action and
called in it worked Christina I was like
you've been on the sidelines you've been
thinking about calling today's your day
thanks for calling man how can we help
what's going on
all right so um I've been doing Davis
for a while and I was debt free until I
decided to request a refund of my
payment towards my student loan debt
that I made since 2020.
and the amount I am expected to receive
is thirty three thousand five hundred
and four dollars hold up you you took
the whole thing
yeah oh boy what made you decide to take
the whole thing
um so I recently
um purchased a condo and I just figured
that
um having as much money as I could have
would help with the remodeling of the
home and also just keeping up with the
payments of the house
but you worked really hard to pay it off
you were super motivated to pay off the
student loan initially correct
and then what kind of change since then
um I just like I had this like issue get
into real estate become a real estate
investor and and grow my will through
real estate how old are you
I'm 26 years old okay did you did you
watch a few too many tick tocks is this
what happened no I'm actually really big
on podcasts and um I've been listening
to other real estate podcasts yeah okay
well the good news is this is a
reversible decision right hopefully you
haven't spent this money yet
no so they're still processing it I
haven't received it yet okay well the
good news is as soon as you receive this
money you're gonna go back and you're
going to pay off that 33 000.
yeah hit the brakes hit the brakes
immediately send that money back you are
Robin Peter to pay Boston
this is like I cashed out my 401k to buy
real estate or I did a cash out refi to
get another property and now I'm further
into debt you're moving backwards
instead of forwards and it looks on
paper like you're doing better but now
we sit here owing 33 that we're gonna
have payments on while we're trying to
make payments on this real estate
property that we're hoping we get a
tenant in and make money off of
and so there's an order to this and I
want you to get into real estate we love
real estate around here but there's a
time and place to do it and that's once
you're completely debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund and I want you to
have your own place first
yeah do you have any other debt outside
of the 33
uh no I'm completely debt free I own my
car and I just have my mortgage payments
every month now okay what's what's left
on the mortgage loan
so I just purchased this property I'm in
there a month now okay what's left on
the loan
uh two hundred and seven thousand
dollars okay and what's that monthly
payment
monthly payment is uh fifteen hundred
okay what's your take-home pay
take home pay every month is about five
thousand dollars of accounting the extra
side jobs I do oh nice
okay and I'm assuming that's on a
30-year
yes okay
so right now your payments are about
thirty percent of your income on a
30-year not ideal I would have steered
you to the 15 years the only mortgage I
would ever recommend uh where the
payment's no more than a quarter of your
take on pay so a a good chunk of your
world right now is in this property and
I would encourage you to attack that one
first and then save up and pay cash for
any real estate property you buy in the
future for investing
okay yeah and you've you've done this
right like you were on the right path
you have felt this motivation and the
thing is is that student loan debt
you've paid it off it's already it's
already been paid off and now you can
save up money and do this the right way
you can go through baby steps four
through six you can pay off a house you
can then go on to baby step seven and
build wealth and give we're not talking
about someone who's never been motivated
to pay off debt we're talking about
someone who's done it before don't lose
your way now yeah you're a sharp 26 year
old guy I mean if you had a car payment
and you had 25 000 on the loan you paid
off 25 would you then as soon as you
became debt free go out and take another
25 000 loan for fun
no but there is also the new thing that
the government is forgiving twenty to
ten thousand dollars of college debt so
I was maybe if I could take it that's a
big maybe and right now you for sure are
back 33 000 in debt that's a guarantee
also did you have a Pell Grant
um my last semester I did so I don't
know if that qualifies me okay I would
figure that out because
um if you had a Pell Grant you should
qualify for 20 but if you didn't it
would only be 10 but regardless you
still have more debt over and above that
you're still further into debt with the
extra 13. even if forgiveness happens
well and I think the good news is you've
done stupid but you can still get smart
yes you can turn around this is
reversible if you so choose please
please please do not go out and get
investment property while you have this
mortgage while you now have the student
loan this is a nightmare waiting to
happen and you called in because you
felt like this was not a good idea and I
hope we convince you that this was not a
good idea and that we slow down and yes
it may be years before you start
becoming a real estate Guru investor but
it's time to put down the podcast
telling you to go up to your eyeballs in
debt so that you can have this amazing
life and have all this cash flow and
passive income it's a lie from the pit
of Hell Matthias don't fall for this if
you need to stop listening to those
podcasts for a while that's probably the
best thing to do well and George's
that's kind
of with all of the student loan
forgiveness is that it's somehow going
to change people's perception of debt so
that they think it's okay because they
go well they forgave at that time so
I'll just go in a bunch of credit card
debt because I probably get forgiven
right
no it's not how it works and even just
that mindset shift of okay I might have
ten or twenty thousand dollars forgiven
so now I should ask for a 33 000 refund
this drives me crazy and it may the
thing I'm angry about with student loan
forgiveness is not people getting help
that's not it at all it's the precedent
that it sets that I can just go into
debt because someone will forgive it
down the line and it's not my problem
anymore and we've lost all
accountability and responsibility as a
society because we've decided to go you
know what I'm going to Outsource all my
problems it's not my problem you guys
made me in debt no you signed on the
dotted line right with any type of debt
this isn't just student loans with
credit cards with car payments and we
have to start making better decisions
for our future that our future selves
would high five us for and rarely in
history has debt been a thing you look
back and go man that's what really saved
me is going into a hundred thousand in
student loan debt and having a car
payment that's what blessed me
financially no when you don't have any
debt you make different decisions when
you have to use your own money you make
different decisions when you have to go
to college and pay for it you make
different decisions of where you go to
school right well now they're saying
with the income-based repayment program
the modifications to it where it's
capped at five percent of your income
the danger and risk is in that is that
students in the future will go oh well I
can just take out as much student loan
debt as I want because it's going to be
it's going to be only five percent of my
income so why not live in a fancy house
off campus why not max out my meal plan
because it's going to be capped I don't
have to guess what happens then the
colleges go oh my gosh guys we can raise
prices a thousand percent because the
kids are going to take out as many
student loans as it takes to go here and
have this life and they're only going to
pay five percent of the loan with their
income and so it doesn't matter
that's the scary part is we're going to
continue to see these numbers Skyrocket
yeah the trickle-down effect the
long-term repercussions I think that I
I'm not saying that there were bad
intentions in it I think there were good
intentions but what are the long-term
impacts what's going to be the ripple
effect we've been fighting for so long
with borrowed future with the things
we've been doing to get students to go
to school debt free we want to change
perspective and help people realize they
don't need debt to get their education
but it's kind of scary thinking how is
this going to change people's
perspectives is it going to make people
feel a little bit more free and easy
around debt and just think oh it's not a
big deal like I'll just get my 33 000
back as easy to access and convenient
and a shortcut people will continue to
take it and so it's time for the
government to stop guaranteeing this
risk-free on behalf of the student loan
companies terrible idea right and if you
are a parent or you are a mentor or
someone who loves a student encourage
them to go to school debt free and also
if you have someone in your life who has
student loans and is waiting for a
refund remind them if they still have
money beyond that refund they have to
start paying in January like there is
still responsibility around these loans
all right this that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show and the books big thanks
to everyone in the booth to my co-host
George Campbell and to you America
thanks for listening we'll be back soon
you love a good day Brandt want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]